your whole thing with you were saying
like how leaving saying leaving saying
and how women always left alone with the
kid to be honest I feel like women are
always alone with the kid because
they're not choosing the right man and
they're having they're having children
out of web Wayne
they're they're having children out of
wedlock so already it's it's set up for
[__] disaster yeah agree you're
having kids out of wedlock most the time
it's not going to work and I'll tell you
that staying for the sake kid what
happened with my parents my parents
separated on and off my whole life gave
me very inconsistent lifestyle so that's
why women are always alone with children
because they're doing it the wrong way
yeah yeah
but guys guys let her finish %. I don't
know statistic I'm not that [__] who
knows stats and [__] I really don't like
you said live off the real world and
that's what I see all of my friends
single moms because they're [__] baby
daddies or piece of [__] yeah because
historically women are all the ones
who've been the caregivers of those
children so naturally the woman is going
to be left left with the
child wouldn't happen if they chose a
traditional man that's all NE I don't
think that guys are a piece of [__] I
think sometimes women have babies to try
and trap men and too men do that as well
men do that as well cuz men are just
sick circumstantial okay what what were
you saying you were saying something
before she cut you off I said that it's
not always that the woman that leaves
the man it's not always the woman that
looks at start again it's the women who
normally looks after the child because
historically that's always what's been
the case because traditionally the woman
is the one who stays at home
Cooks but why but why are we punishing
the men for doing what they're supposed
to do like you want you got wait wait
you want a guy that protects and
provides right that's what we
traditionally want but when a guy do
does it he loses his kids no one said
that's what we should punish them cuz
like men and women are different men go
and build houses women look after the
kids women build houses men can look
after kids there are stay home dads who
do exactly the same job as women when
the women are out there earning the
bread like that's minority it's a
minority but it does happen so you need
to you need to accept that happen we
know like duh ackn it but it's like we
don't have to we just said let's not
acknowledge every exception we know
there's every there was are exceptions
and you the first thing you say here's
the exception we know we know I think
what the lady is simply doing is trying
to bring up the facts and I agree that
we should actually be holding men and
women equally accountable because we
should be saying that there are men who
should take responsibility think let me
finish let me finish I was speaking no
no again it's not okay get out go go bye
I told you now I told you a millionth
time I haven't done anything wrong okay
all right bye why what why why do you
want me to all right I'm asking you to
go thank you you don't like the fact
that I'm challenging your viewpoints no
I don't really people challenge my
viewpoints all the time I don't I don't
like that you're being rude I'm not
being
rude
okay like meet
feminists po do you not like it when
people have all their opinions no her
she asked her to stop multiple times and
she didn't there's a rule we were told
the rules before we came so yeah but she
did try and talk a few times and P and
didn't let her talk you just told a show
all right all right because it's not
your show if you want to put on a show
and talk when you want to talk I already
put on a show not that good I've never
heard of it it's only fans hand you not
know
l
live streams every Friday and Saturday
oh my God on
Sunday all right um what were we talking
about uh exceptions and women in the
minority okay um and children babies
kids yeah so all right who here thinks
women make better decisions than men no